[Music]
Robert Spencer here for jihad watch a
program of the David hardwoods freedom
Center and for the center for security
policy our longtime friend and Ally
Pakistan recently showed yet again which
side it's really on the Pakistani
government released Hafiz Saeed from
house arrest a fizz Syed is the
mastermind of the 2008 Mumbai jihad
massacre and he is a man with a ten
million dollar US bounty on his head
the Pakistanis didn't release Saeed into
US custody but to freedom and the
adulation of his jihad supporting
countrymen as well as those in India TNN
reported that police were on their toes
in Lok in poor City on Friday morning
after members of a community allegedly
celebrated the release of Mumbai terror
attack mastermind and co-founder of
lashkar-e-taiba
Hafiz Saeed in Pakistan lashkar-e-taiba
is a prominent Pakistani jihad group the
report went on some residents of Begum
bog
colony in shiv puri area allegedly
decorated their houses with green flags
and also raised slogans like Hafiz Saeed
zindabad and Pakistan zindabad the issue
was immediately brought to district
magistrate Akash deeps notice after
which police force was rushed to the
colony now Saeed is even more popular in
Pakistan itself which may be why the
Islamic Republic is so far ignored us
calls to read if they did arrest him
again they could be facing even more
riots by Islamic hardliners and
Pakistani government officials have
already been recently dealing with riots
in of Islamabad that have killed six
people and wounded 200 as Islamic
supremacists demanded the arrest of a
government official on blasphemy charges
those riots are hardly the hallmark of a
moderate or Western oriented nation and
they are all the more reason why the
sham alliance between the US and
Pakistan needs to be ended Financial
Times reported in September 2017 that
the Trump administration is considering
dropping Pakistan as an ally as it
examines tough measures to
more than 20 terrorist groups it says
her based in the country president Trump
needs to follow through on that Trump
has accused the Pakistani government of
housing the very terrorists that we are
fighting and it's true with the most
notorious of these being of sama bin
Laden himself before he was killed
journalist Carlotta gall who reported
from Afghanistan for The New York Times
for 12 years reported in March 2014 that
soon after the Navy SEAL raid on bin
Laden's house a Pakistani official told
me that the United States had direct
evidence that the ISI Chief Lieutenant
General Ahmed Shuja Pasha knew of bin
Laden's presence in Abbottabad the
information came from a senior United
States official and I guess that the
Americans had intercepted a phone call
of Pasha's or one about him in the days
after the raid he knew of osama's
whereabouts yes the Pakistani official
told me the official was surprised to
learn this and said the Americans were
even more so he shouldn't have been but
the denial continues Barack Obama
speaking in India in December 17 claimed
that the Pakistani government had no
idea that bin Laden was there but
actually it was obvious for years and
remains obvious that the Pakistanis had
been aiding the same jihadists that the
US government has been giving them
billions of dollars to fight the New
York Times reported on that at length
way back in 2008 not only did Ahmed
Shuja Pasha the head of the Pakistani
government spy service know the
whereabouts of Osama bin Laden but so
did many other top officials in the
Pakistani government the Pakistani
government meanwhile is getting US money
to fight terrorists to this day this is
what they're using it for Sky News
reported in January 2014 that Pakistani
officials have reportedly used a secret
counterterrorism fund to buy wedding
gifts luxury carpets and gold jewellery
for relatives of ministers and visiting
dignitaries this is better than
funneling to the terrorists themselves
the money that the government has
received from the u.s. to fight terror
but they're doing that as well and all
this shows how seriously the Pakistani
authorities have taken the
role in the war on terror that is not
seriously at all three years have passed
since these facts were revealed the
Obama administration of course never did
anything about them Trump needs to take
action for far too many years now the US
government has been suffering from a
strange addiction to shoveling huge
amounts of money to old Cold War allies
that aren't really allies at all the end
of this farce with Pakistan should have
come long ago we can only hope that
Trump will now act upon his remarkably
clear sided view of this SH an ally I'm
Robert Spitzer
[Music]